this morning a man is in custody after
crashing his off-road vehicle on
christmas eve 26-year-old yasmani
flahman faces a reckless driving charge
now his sister was a passenger and she
lost one of her arms in that crash as
madison kimbrough explains though she
says her brother does not deserve the
blame
i made that sharp right turn the vehicle
spun out of control
and it ended up falling
to the right side
and i put my arm out because i had tried
to like you know stop the fall out of
instinct and my arm got caught isabella
hernandez is recovering at umc after
doctors amputated her right arm
following the christmas eve crash nlvpd
charging her brother 26 year old yasmani
flamen with reckless driving hernandez
says lemon is not to blame as it was an
accident and she believes he was not
being reckless it was unjustified there
was no reason for him to go to jail we
had just pulled into the parking lot he
was going at 26. he had he wasn't
drinking that night he wasn't he wasn't
on anything he was completely sober
hernandez says when police got to the
scene they assured the family he would
not be arrested she also says officers
told her impairment was not a factor in
the crash daniel vargas hernandez's
boyfriend was also in the u-t-v when the
crash happened i'm just devastated
heartbroken you know
we have a
young lady 20 20 years old who's just
lost
almost her whole arm he walked away okay
but says the lasting effects of what
happened will change him forever i ended
up flying out and i hit my head pretty
hard i was able to
cover with this if not would have hit my
whole hand so thankfully
my my oh my hand saved me i think you
know from probably dying madison
kimbrough 8 news now